"Notre histoire commence sous un grand manteau blanc,"
"Dans le chalet du vieil homme préféré des enfants."
"Le Père-Noël, assis à son bureau,"
"Lisait toutes les lettres de ces gentils marmots."
"Et lorsqu’il leva son regard,"
"Il vit deux hommes et une femme avec de très jolis costards."
Bonjour Monsieur Noël. Je suis John Delay,
PDG de "King Toys."
Voici Mademoiselle Mona de "Fisher Game"
et Monsieur Bill de "Le Monde du Joujou."
Tous les enfants ont droit à un joujou.
- Oui Bill.
Ok.
"Le Père-Noël trempa son cookie dans son verre de lait,"
"Tout en écoutant le charabia de la marchande de jouets."
Ecoutez Monsieur Noël,
l’économie mondiale ne s’est jamais aussi bien portée.
Alors, votre artisanat là avec vos petits lutins, c’est bien mignon.
Mais on est en 1957 Monsieur Noël,
il faut passer à une production industrielle plus massive.
Hein, on se sort les grelots maintenant.
Mes petits lutins mettent beaucoup de cœur à l’ouvrage,
Et fabriquent suffisamment de jouets pour tous les enfants sages.
Ok.
Ça rime, ok, mais c’est complètement con.
Ho ho ho,
Etre sages toute l’année,
et recevoir un cadeau pour être récompensé,
tel est l’esprit de Noël,
que l’on retrouve dans chaque foyer.
Je sens que ça va vite me saouler les rimes moi.
Alors, j’entends votre point de vue Monsieur Noël.
Mais j’attire sur votre attention sur le fait que notre cœur de cible,
les 5-15 ans,
est quand même majoritairement composée de petits merdeux capricieux.
Du coup, si on se prive de tous les enfants pas sages,
quelque part on s’exclue d’un marché assez...
lucratif.
Je ne vois pas ce que vous voulez dire.
Où voulez-vous en venir?
Nous souhaiterions vous racheter Noël.
Moi, Monsieur et Mademoiselle.
Ah non,
excusez-moi.
Tu vas pas commencer à faire des rimes toi aussi.
Me racheter Noël, mais ça va pas bien?
Je viens à peine de le racheter aux Chrétiens.
"L’un des affreux compères sorti de sa besace un contrat,"
"Qui parlait d’exclusivité, de délocalisation et de rachat."
"En lisant ces mots,"
"le Père Noël n’en revenait pas,"
"On voulait même l’utiliser pour une marque de sodas."
"Les trois associés n’avaient vraiment pas l’air réglos,"
"Le Père-Noël se leva"
"et leur tourna le dos."
Si je m’occupe de Noël c’est pour célébrer cette merveilleuse nuit,
Un soir dans l’année où l’on oublie nos problèmes, nos soucis.
Où les familles se retrouvent autour d’un bon souper,
Où les enfants s’amusent avec leurs nouveaux jouets.
Où le plus vieux de la famille se retrouve …
Il me semble avoir prévenu que j’en avais plein le cul des rimes.
Et puis ça sert à rien de discuter avec des gens comme lui,
ils comprennent rien.
S’il veut pas distribuer nos cadeaux,
on dira aux parents de venir les chercher dans nos magasins,
et puis c’est terminé.
Non?
Ok,
et qu’est-ce qu’on fait de lui maintenant?
Alors, moi j’ai peut-être une idée.
"L’un des trois compères découpa le vieil homme à la disqueuse."
"La tâche fut galère"
"et extrêmement fastidieuse."
J’ai touché un truc là.
"Puis ils balancèrent les morceaux dans la cheminée,"
"Quelque part, le Père-Noël connaissait déjà le trajet."
Les gens vont remarquer qu’il a disparu.
Ils vont finir par s’en douter.
Un type aussi gentil que le Père-Noël,
ils se diront qu’il n’a jamais existé.
Alors, sans déconner,
elle est encore branchée.
Alors il va vraiment falloir arrêter de m’emmerder avec les rimes
si vous voulez pas finir avec le vieux là-dedans.
Toi, t’es bougon depuis tout  à l’heure.
Moi?
Si, t’es bougon.
C’est pas agréable d’être en ta compagnie depuis tout à l’heure.
Pose ça.
Tu veux du lait?